Have you ever wondered, what gives eyes their color? The short answer to this
question is that Melanin, a pigment, is deposited in the Iris of the eye to give
the apparent color. Soon after birth, Melanocytes,
the same type of cells that confer skin
pigmentation. Begin to synthesize and deposit melanin pigment.
Now, if we look at the iris here,
we'd have to zoom in to see the
melanocytes here. And there's a special structure within
the melanocyte cell called the Melanosome that synthesizes
and deposits this melanin pigment. Now, normally the kind
of pigment that's produced is very dark pigment.
And if there's an abundance of this dark melanin,
then the cell layer is thick. Most incoming
light is absorbed and the eyecolor will appear brown.
On the other hand, it is only a little pigment and the thin layer of
cells, then little light is absorbed. And the
eye will appear blue. All intermediate shades reflect
variations on this theme. The amount of
melanin produced combined with the thickness of the
cell layers affecting how much light is reflected
or absorbed. While Eye Color is polygenic and
affected by several different genes. OCA2 or OCA2 plays the largest role.
[UNKNOWN]
with a fully functioning OCA2 produce a lot of dark
pigment, which results in brown eyes.
[UNKNOWN]
without a fully functioning OCA2 produce almost
no pigment, resulting in blue eyes. When the
OCA2 gene's function is reduced by other mutations,
various eye colors from blue to hazelcan result.
Based on this, I want you to rate the following OCA2 variations on a scale from
Brownest to Bluest. You're going to use the numbers
one, two, and three to rank these three
options, one being the brownest and three being
the bluest, and two being in the middle.
[UNKNOWN]
two copies of a silent mutation in OCA2, two copies of a nonsense mutation
in OCA2. And one copy of a
Mutation in the OCA2 promoter that reduces transcription.